there's always a story of the month me
dating jennifer lopez happened to be
that tabloid story at the time
when that business grew exponentially
when they realized there's there's
actually 10 times a bigger audience
for our product than we're selling too
that's ben affleck
reflecting on his relationship with
jennifer lopez over
15 years ago at first it was like dick
and liz it was this sort of infatuation
what an interesting couple and then
there was a ton of resentment hundreds
of men against me a ton of resentment
against jennifer
while being interviewed on the hollywood
reporters award chatter podcast on
thursday
the 48 year old actor recalled the
never-ending spotlight on their romance
in the early 2000s
which you might remember as the era of
benefir
we're trying to get some can you see if
we can get in the papers
because i'm trying to get could i could
i listen and affleck has some harsh
words for their critics at the time
people were so keen about her
sexist racist you know ugly
vicious was written about her in ways
that
if you wrote it now you would literally
be fired you're saying
you said affleck also highlights the
brighter side of this story
in the years since the overwhelming
praise lopez has received for her
wide-ranging career
now it's like she's lionized and
respected
for the work she did where she came from
what she accomplished as well she should
be
but some things never change both
affleck and lopez are still in highly
publicized romances
lopez is engaged to baseball star alex
rodriguez
and affleck seemingly commented on his
recent string of viral snapshots near
his home
many of them featuring his girlfriend
anna de armas
this day they'll go like you know i see
you out there like in the paparazzi in
the pictures it's like yes i left my
house and took out the trash
i want to give it away but it has a very
good ending affleck and lopez began
dating in 2002
quickly followed by the couple
announcing their engagement
why don't we try and make this pleasant
okay they co-starred in the movies geely
and jersey girl and affleck famously
cameoed in jlo's iconic music video
jenny from the block
[Music]
but in 2003 the wedding was called off
just days before their planned ceremony
in september
and benefer officially went their
separate ways in january 2004.
well i will ask you because in the book
you also said that ben was your first
heartbreak
it was my first year it was my first
kind of heartbreak lopez opened up to et
in 2014
about her and affleck split i mean i had
like a puppy love heartbreak when i was
like 12.
you know what i mean but i don't really
count that one it was my first like
adult heartbreak
was it because it was so public and we
wanted to know every single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help
sorry that didn't help but um
no it was just it was just one of those
things you know i was an adult
we were about to get married it didn't
work out and it was just
a bad heartbreak like you know just one
of those breakups that really
you know it was like a tough one for me
for whatever reason for many reasons
[Music]